[Music]
Callisto protocol has a disappointing
story because all I see when playing is
potential that was never fully
recognized it has the foundations of
something that can be a compelling story
but it's never seen in this game and
today I want to talk about why the point
is to not only talk about the story of
Callisto protocol but also critique it
along the way so as always spoiler
warning ahead without further Ado though
let's get started so as always some
background on Callisto protocol we play
as Jacob Lee a cargo pilot Jacob and his
partner Max are currently transporting
items to Callisto one of Jupiter's moons
two of them have been watching a news
report about an attack on the planet
Europa which seems to have been started
by a terrorist group called the outer
way Max seems to be quite scared by this
news but Jacob doesn't seem to care
after seeing that there was an alert on
the ship Jacob checks it out and
discovers that they've been boarded and
by none other than outer way and their
leader Dany the two barely managed to
fend them off but have to crash land on
the moon in order to do so sadly Max
dies in the crash but Jacob lives Jacob
isn't taken by a captain Ferris along
with with Danny and the two are sent to
Black Iron prison already the plot is
starting off strong there are a lot of
questions that the player will have by
now such as why are we in prison are we
going to be able to escape is this just
a misunderstanding and what did Danny
and her people want with us it's a great
start and this mystery adds to the
horror especially when we wake up and
realize that the prison is out of
control not only are the prisoners
running around but these zombified
people are attacking everyone in sight
around this time is when the player will
get the chance to do some combat and by
now it's becoming quite clear that lots
of Callisto protocol systems are taking
inspiration from Dead Space the HUD
elements and some of the gameplay
abilities are identical to that of the
Dead Space series however I don't think
it was just the gameplay that took
inspiration I would argue that not only
is Callisto protocols plot eerily
similar to Dead Space 1 but I'd argue
it's almost a one-to-one recreation of
the story from its structure to the
method of Storytelling to the
withholding of key details until the
final chapters to even the antagonists
and their motivations everything is the
same and that's the confusing bit I love
dead space 1. I made an entire video a
month ago analyzing the trailer story
that you might enjoy and I said in that
video that Dead Space 1 is the best out
of the three because the way it sets the
tone for the series while also
transitioning from active plot to
overarching plot in a seamless way so
with that in mind I should like list a
protocol since it's the exact same but I
don't custom protocol story is like Dead
Space 1 but it's only skin deep there
are very specific reasons why that
game's story is as incredible as it is
inaccalist or protocol never took notes
on what those reasons actually were like
many reviewers I will be comparing this
game to Dead Space a lot but I want to
use the game as a way to reinforce my
arguments I want to explain what
Callisto protocol tried to do and then
explain how dead space did it right for
example its characters Dany and Elias
are the two main members of The
Supporting Cast they and Jacob will work
together to escape the prison the
problem is that I know next to nothing
about them and these heartfelt moments
the group has comes off his out of
nowhere and confusing I'll talk about
Danny a bit later since she is related
to the ending but as for Elias he's
another inmate here at the prison and he
needs Jacob's help in order to escape
the two then work together to do just
that until they make it outside the
prison the two will eventually get some
downtime which prompts Jacob to ask what
Elias was in for Elias then tells him
that he killed someone and he says that
it was in self-defense and that he was
in the wrong place at the wrong time
Jacob reassures him though and says that
it's all right you just got dealt a bad
hand is all Elias disagrees though and
says that he's used to blaming others
but now he needs to start blaming
himself his final line of dialogue is
quote you can't keep running from what
you've done this was not just a line for
Elias but for Jacob given the final few
scenes of the game I do appreciate this
line a bit more now that I have finished
the game but we'll discuss that later
because the focus is on Elias now but
this chat provides us with nothing who
did he kill why was it in self-defense
and what was he doing that caused this
to happen in the first place we don't
learn anything and we never will learn
anything because 10 minutes from now
Elias dies Captain Ferris sucked them
out of the room and they fell quite far
I'm used to calling characters like this
one note meaning they're only known for
one thing but I can't even do that with
Elias he's just a prisoner that's all he
has as much depth as any other prisoner
we've seen running away from the
infected with the only difference being
that we actually know his name contrast
this with Dead Space 1 which had a cast
of characters that had more personality
to them a lot of the combat Arenas in
that game are broken up by long
stretches of dialogue your teammates and
enemies have so much personality that
they always seem to take Center Stage
when they're involved like Kendra's
mystery and goal in Dr Mercer's Devotion
to the Necromorphs Hammond is definitely
on the low end of quality but he at
least makes you care about him in some
way I never really felt connected to
Dany and Elias I like their performances
but the writing didn't provide enough
details about them for me to actually
care about who they were furthermore
Elias's death also confuses me greatly
because Callisto protocol has a weird
relationship with oxygen right after the
two get thrown out of the room Jacob
struggles to flip the visor down on his
mask he is clearly choking due to lack
of air and can't even speak since his
mouth can't intake any error however
Elias has a cracked helmet and yet not
only is he still alive despite being
deprived of oxygen for a few minutes but
is also just completely fine minus the
fact that he may have some severe
physical injuries from the crash
speaking of crashes when Max and Jacob
crash land on Callisto Captain Ferris
cuts a hole through the side of the
cockpit to get to them he walks in with
a mask on implying that without it they
wouldn't be able to breathe yet Jacob is
completely fine even though the cockpit
is now completely exposed to callisto's
Atmosphere so technically he should be
choking just like he was earlier we even
returned to the ship at the end of the
game and he still keeps the helmet on so
all of this is just incredibly
inconsistent one could possibly argue
that Callisto has normal oxygen and The
Masks are used for other purposes I
personally don't think that's the case
but even if it were a possibility we
would never know as Callisto protocol's
other issue is World building Callisto
protocol's world is about as tight as
its linear corridors both Dead Space 1
and Callisto protocol have audio logs
that you can read to learn more about
the world but Deadspace 1 took full
advantage of this from the first game
alone we learned that the world of dead
space is star for resources and that
mining companies had to Planet crack
other planets for those resources that
they could sustain the population it was
a Dying World that was in desperate need
of help and this desperation is how the
USG ishimura made it to age 7 and
unknowingly stumbled upon the marker we
also learned that unitology is a popular
religion in the Dead Space world that
worships these markers for at the time
an unknown reason it also managed to
connect unitology to the state of the
world unitology promised those who
joined a better life and since Dead
Space was a world filled with despair
thanks to overpopulation and a lack of
resources praying that the next life is
better makes sense Deadspace 1 made the
world feel bigger than just the ishimura
Kalisto protocol never capitalized on
this despite being in a world where
Humanity has not only mastered space
travel but has colonized the moon on
Jupiter nothing other than the prison is
mentioned we never hear about the
goings-on of the world and how humanity
is doing not only does Callisto protocol
not give us details about anything in
the solar system but we barely even get
to learn info on the moon itself besides
one important detail at the end Callisto
protocol is in game and in lore confined
to its own prison cell all of this could
have been remedied though if the game
had committed to making better audio
logs almost every audio log in the game
is post outbreak meaning we have very
little information about the prison
prior to the infection so many of these
audio logs are just people screaming
dying or screaming and dying there are
thankfully some great audio logs that
talk about secret plans and tests on
prisoners and wouldn't you believe it
they all take place before the outbreak
almost as if that idea works it's not
the fact that the audio logs during the
outbreak are bad it's just that so many
of them take place around that time and
what else would be happening at a point
in time like this besides people dying
and screaming the viral Outbreak The
Game Calls the biophage is only centered
around black Iron prison and for all we
know a street on Europa that's an
incredibly narrow reach and doesn't give
us enough info to speculate or indulge
in continuing the theme of mimicking
Dead Space Callisto protocol has rarely
any story until the final few chapters
Dead Space 1 had the main goal of
escaping the ishimura which was the
active plot then in chapter 9 the game
transitioned to a more overarching plot
as more details about the marker and
unitology were becoming known Callisto
protocol does the same thing but somehow
fails despite having a longer run time
thus having more time to flesh out the
story The Early chapters do at least get
the player thinking about what's going
on since the warden of the prison Duncan
Cole is rather calm even though there is
an outbreak in his own prison this is
also further solidified by the secret
rooms we can find in some of the levels
there are a couple rooms in Callisto
protocol that have this strange Insignia
plastered all over the walls implying
that a secret group was hiding away from
the rest of the prison and conversing
with one another this was an excellent
use of environmental storytelling as it
teases to the play that something else
is going on here and for as much as I
dislike most of this game's story I will
say that during the playthrough I was
very interested in the story and where
they were planning on taking the story
next it's a shame though that a lot of
this was lost almost immediately since
there's very little story that actually
happens in those early chapters I don't
mind if the game purposely withholds
information so can be revealed in a big
plot twist but almost everything outside
of that is just centered around pushing
forward there are no discussions about
each other or why the prison is even
here to begin with none of that gets
mentioned until chapter 6. honestly from
a story point of view you can go right
from the prison break to chapter 6 and
Miss pretty much nothing and that's
disappoint the one thing you will miss
though is the visuals glister protocol
may not feel like a horror game but it
definitely looks like one and its
visuals really sold the idea that we
were on a different planet fighting for
our lives against the waves of infected
Prisoners the game takes a lot of the
good qualities that Dead Space 2's
opening levels had since that game also
started mid-outbreak on the ishimura the
Necromorphs had time to lie in wait
that's why it felt so terrifying to walk
through the ship's Halls Dead Space 2
was mid-outbreak which is why more
explosions were added and why things
felt more in the moment there wasn't
time to analyze things or plan ahead the
outbreak is happening right now and
you're in the middle of it so just keep
running now Callisto protocol doesn't
fully commit to this idea in the same
way as Dead Space 2 since there is a
severe lack of survivors in this game
besides Elias Danny and Jacob but it
does still get a lot of the feel right
once Elias and Jacob free themselves
from the main hall the two pushed
forward towards solitary confinement
since there's a prisoner there that they
will need on the way there though Jacob
will start seeing visions of an infected
on an operating table the being is
restrained but manages to escape and
kill the doctors according to Elias the
implant Jacob has on his neck takes a
bit of time to get used to and thus is
prone to this kind of behavior one could
argue though that it's not random and
that it's someone sending these to Jacob
at one point in the game Jacob and Elias
have to go radio silences they're going
to be out of range of each other but
Elias uploads his memories through the
implant on their neck this is to help
Jacob progress through the area and as
we can see Elias is looking at different
pipes and trying to find out different
things about this part of the facility
this was sent to him by Elias so it's
possible that this scene with the
infected was sent to him by someone else
it is a massive stretch for sure and I'm
likely thinking about it too much since
this was probably just a lazy and
unexplained way to show some of the
story beats but it's at least somewhat
interesting to think about once the two
Mega too solitary confinement though
they'll find the prisoner they need who
just happens to be Dany I really like
Danny's cold attitude but I do kind of
wish he stayed with the group a bit as
she continues her journey on her own for
a while it would have made the group
dynamic quite interesting giving their
different personalities and their
opinions Danny then locks Jacob and
herself and the group has to split off
and reunite somewhere else Elias and
Jacob will then meet for the last time
since Captain Ferris is here and sucks
them out of the room which leads to the
sequence of events we talked about
earlier the last time Ferris was seen
was around chapter 2 and was thrown out
the Watchtower so him being here and
also being partially mutated is not only
connected but concerning Danny and Jacob
then meet again and the two finally
managed to get along the reason she was
so hostile to Jacob in the beginning was
that she heard that he was smuggling
biochemical weapons Jacob says that they
were only medical supplies and well they
technically were but not any kind of
traditional medicine the medicine
they've been carrying was the virus that
infected black Iron and Europa Jacob was
a pilot and given his nonchalant
attitude he figured it'd be best to just
do the job and not ask questions this
would cause thousands of people to die
on Europa though as he delivered the
virus right to them Warden Cole wanted
to test the strain to see its
Effectiveness and after seeing its
vicious nature on Europa he determined
that it was time to see it again in
Black Iron
this event changes Jacob as he feels
immense regret and guilt over his
decision claiming that he could have
stopped all this from happening these
kinds of moments in Callisto protocol
were few and far between but I welcome
them nonetheless because the story
wasn't about pushing forward anymore it
was about guilt and whether or not Jacob
deserves to be punished for what he did
Jacob started becoming an actual
character it just took nine hours for
that to happen as for Danny she'll sadly
suffer the same fate as Elias as she
doesn't go anywhere in regards to her
character although I am willing to
overlook this due to the setup of the
ending plus there was the reveal that
she wasn't actually a terrorist and the
ujc was actually just fabricating a lot
of the evidence on Europa once the duo
makes it back to Jacob's ship is really
where the story starts to pick up some
speed I'll be honest I was grinning from
ear to ear when going through these
areas since the story was really
starting to show all of its layers which
is why despite the fact that I wasn't an
avid fan of the story I really do think
a sequel can honestly iron this out and
we can all look back on this as a slow
start to a great series because I do
think there is something salvageable
amongst this wreckage the main plot
details we learn here are nothing out of
the ordinary and are pretty much
identical the Dead Space again but the
beauty of dead space was how it took
alien life and made it Sinister
Necromorphs from their design to their
insatiable hunger made them a fantastic
antagonist to the story and I think the
biophage could have that too Danny and
Jacob make it to the hangar but Ward and
Cole notices and shoots down the ship
they were going to use to get out of
here did any questions the decision on
why he would shoot his own ship and
that's because as we talked about
earlier this is all a test to the warden
he wants to see the infection spread for
a very specific reason below black Iron
prism was a colony called Arcus these
people like anyone lived out their lives
in peace trying to make ends meet this
settlement though was a mining town so
many miners would carve out large chunks
of rock in order to get paid
unfortunately one dug too deep and came
across an alien life form the security
team stationed at the settlement shot it
on site though thankfully it was dead
but inside the alien were thousands of
larva that were still alive these then
latched onto the crew and somehow got
inside them this caused widespread
sickness to occur people were dying and
going crazy yet no one knew why these
people would eventually become the
infected we see at the mining town and
more importantly the ones that are blind
early earlier in that level Dr Mahler
was then called to look into the
sickness and discovered that the
symptomology was familiar to her
apparently it was a form of accelerated
Evolution similar to an incident in
paramo now paramo is never actually
mentioned in game but it is most likely
a reference to the map paramo in Pub G
yes the Battle Royale game some of you
might know why I'm referencing this game
but if you don't I'll get to that later
since the symptoms were similar Dr
Muller believes that if they can
understand the disease they could
re-engineer it allowing them to unlock
the secrets of the paramo effect Dr
Mahler among many others then set up a
lab as well as a prison on top of the
colony so they could have a steady
supply of test subjects this is the true
reason behind black iron's creation it
was just a glorified testing ground
before they released the biophage on
black Iron though they tested it out on
Europa with the help of a pilot who was
never told any official details the test
however became a success because one
person had managed to survive the
infection a person they dubbed subject
zero zero was eventually killed by
security but it showed that this was
possible black iron's outbreak was a
test to get the new subject zero now
called subject Alpha if they could have
one person survive the infection and
that proves that with the right
conditions Humanity can truly evolve
this subject Alpha is eventually
revealed to be Captain Ferris himself
he's the only one who has survived the
infection and as we can see he's gotten
stronger and more agile this is great
news for Dr Mahler and Warden Cole but
not so great for us since he wants to
fight but sadly due to the combat this
fight is just an inconvenience
regardless though this is what I was
finally waiting for it took so long for
it to get going but just as the
experiment proved that Humanity can
evolve this proves Callisto protocol has
something special here it was just too
afraid to show it until now admittedly
though this is just a big info dump if
we're being honest but given that up
until this point we have gotten next to
nothing I'm almost considering looking
past it after the fight with Captain
Ferris is where Dany gets infected by
one of these slugs she then starts to
lose herself a bit so we need to get her
some help sadly we're then knocked out
by security Bots and thrown back in jail
but Dr Mahler comes on the comms and
says that she can help us this is
strange since we just saw her talk about
the experiment but she claims that she
has had a change of heart and wants to
make things right to get to her though
we'll need to go through some sections
of the prison again and also fight this
two-headed infected once again similar
to Captain Ferris this is just a chore
to sit through especially since the game
forces you to fight this enemy four
different times once we make it to Dr
mahler's lab we can see the test subject
on display as well as what we can assume
is subject zero Dr Muller then says that
she can cure Danny's infection but we
need a sample of Captain Ferris in order
to stop it Jacob then demands that Dr
Mala tell him about what happened on
Europa regarding the infection she then
connects his link with Danny so they can
share memories with each other Danny
also did something like this back at
arcus and it's admittedly a pretty cool
piece of tech but I do wish it was used
more in the game part of me though does
wonder what would happen if they paired
this with the audio logs so instead of
ripping out the implant as they have now
what if chick appears into their
memories this would mean instead of a
log that plays audio of a person
screaming we could see how they died the
game already commits to its Gore so it
wouldn't feel out of place Jacob then
gets the memories of Dany and discovers
what we talked about before about how
Jacob was the cause of the outbreak
since he delivered the volume to Europa
we also learned that Danny's sister Lily
died which is why this mission is so
personal to her Jacob then leaves Danny
behind so she can rest while he deals
with Captain Ferris and it's here where
the environment does a complete 180. it
was inevitable that something like this
would happen but it's something I've
always loved seeing the dichotomy
between the warden's room and the rest
of the prison creates a shift in
priority almost as if the game is saying
that the active plot is over and is now
time to talk about the real threat we
then meet with Warden Cole and his
associates callista protocol like dead
space has its own secret society of
people but instead of unitology it seems
to be called the circle all of them seem
to be in agreeance regarding the forced
evolution of humanity they also have
secret rooms with insignias scattered
throughout the prison and these final
few minutes of the game really solidify
that this is more than just a one-off
outbreak the only problem though is that
it's hard to care about them or look
forward to anything involving them the
circle and its motivations for forced
Evolution are similar to that of the
unitologist from Dead Space the main
difference is being that the biophage
was man-made whereas the Necromorphs
were not created by humanity and the
other being that the presence of
unitology in their game is much more
impactful than the circle we learned
that the unitologists worshiped the
marker and that they sent people from
their organization to board the ishimura
and take the marker back to the church
you knew from that game that something
was going on with the marker and
unitology which is why Dead Space 2
doubled down on it since it was the
proper path to follow the circle which
I'm assuming is the name of the
organization since it's only mentioned
one time in one audio log never actually
shows their face until the final moments
of the game they also never reveal any
reasons for actually wanting an
evolution besides this philosophical
comment about Humanity needing to go
further past the Stars unitology never
needed to reveal their reasons since
Dead Space 1 already gave the player a
compelling enough reason but since we
don't know anything about Callisto
protocol's broader world the only thing
we can assume is that these guys are
just lunatics the group also has their
own catchphrase called beer solitarius
which I think in Latin is a lone male or
a lone survivor which is not nearly as
good as the vegan Sinister make us whole
again but that's just a personal gripe
despite its issues though the basic idea
of a secret society of people trying to
forcefully evolved the world is a
compelling plot and it's why I think a
sequel with the proper writing could do
this back on track it's not that nothing
is here there is it's just not utilized
well and that goes for all of this game
Callisto protocol has characters has
plot has the war has a decent setup but
it's not being utilized to its fullest
like I said it's all skin deep the
characters are likable enough but don't
evolve they never share details with us
and they never give us a chance to care
about them more the game has a story and
a world outside the confines of this
prism but it never seems like any of it
matters the game just withholds
everything about the story until the
final parts of the game and only focuses
on the prison the only way a sequel
could change this is to expand it just
like the Necromorphs went from a threat
against the ship to a threat against
mankind the same can happen here with
the biophage have the circle take these
results and cause more outbreaks on the
planets this will give Jacob motivation
to continue his quest because after
meeting with Warden Cole and defeating
Captain Ferris he saves Dany and sensor
off Planet because he decided that he
needs to stay here Jacob can literally
be this game's Isaac Clark a nobody who
is now on a quest to stop the action
Jacob's actions caused the infection on
Europa and its success caused the black
Iron prison to release its outbreak and
since that was successful to an extent
the circle can replicate this Elsewhere
on other planets Jacob sees this as all
his fault so give him the opportunity to
redeem himself and have him take the
fight to the circle personally I think
this could be a great place to take the
game and could possibly create an
incredible series that started off on
the wrong foot I do not like negatively
reviewing games especially when it's a
game like list or protocol that has the
potential to be great the pieces are
already there they're just waiting to be
moved according to a post-launch roadmap
there seems to be story content that's
coming in the future and this is a
perfect time to set this up I don't
really agree with putting all the juicy
story details in a DLC because then it
seems like a blatant cash grab but
seeing as the end of the game leaves
Jacob on Callisto and Danny somewhere
else with evidence to show the horrors
of the prison the game is really close
to getting back on track here and the
DLC could finally put it on the path to
greatness because as of right now
Callisto protocol feels incomplete and I
feel like there's a major reason why
earlier I mentioned Pub G while Striking
Distance Studios is the developer of
Callisto protocol but they're a
subsidiary of Crafton Crafton owns the
rights to pubg and created starking
distant Studios with the intention of
making story games that have ties to the
pubg universe after some time though the
team realized that their game wasn't
even close to connecting to pubg so they
dropped the connection and made it a
standalone title that game of course
being Callisto protocol this game was
meant to be a part of the pubg universe
which is why that reference to paramo
stands out the question I have though is
when was this decided I haven't played
pubg in probably three years by now so I
have no clue how deep the lore is but I
feel that the concept alone would have
set off some red flags regarding
connectivity furthermore it was supposed
to be about pubg so it was for that
audience jumping into this game blind
without any prior knowledge to Pub G
would be like starting your Mass Effect
Journey with the third game nothing
would make sense since you're playing
the third game in a connected series and
not much would make sense in Callisto
protocol since it's assumed that you're
familiar with the pubg universe the only
article I could find was from May of
2022 when Glenn Schofield director of
Callisto protocol said that the game was
no longer connected to Pub G that's only
seven months ago so how much of this
game was finished by then I feel like
the team had an idea for the story but
then had to fill in the gaps because it
was no longer a part of the universe
however it's unlike Crafton denied their
creation Striking Distance seemed to
make the call themselves so it was
likely discovered early on how divorced
this game ended up becoming from its
original idea all of it is pretty much a
mess but I think this may have had a
hand in some of the quality of the
writing
as a whole though Callisto protocol has
some incredible potential I'm interested
to see the story content they have
planned and whether or not they'll use
it as a bridge to connect another game
or just use it as a way to tie up loose
ends that being said though a lot of
this interest stemmed from the final few
moments because everything else was
pretty much wasted characters are thrown
into the story and they never developed
the world of Callisto protocol seems
isolated the combat hindered the horror
the audio logs didn't help to add more
depth to the world the pacing of the
story was slow in the early chapters and
the main antagonists don't get enough
screen time
here's to hoping though that the game
will improve over time
thank you for watching the video today
and I hope you enjoyed as I said in the
beginning if you like story analysis
content like this then I recommend my
video on the Dead Space series besides
that though we have a ton of other games
on the channel as well with many more to
come part of this game coming out I was
working on the Mass Effect 3 video and
while it's not fully done both
playthroughs are finished and the script
is almost complete so that should be out
in maybe a week or so after that we'll
then tackle Andromeda which will be
quite fun regardless of how that turns
out as always like the video and
subscribe if you're new and thank you to
my returning viewers for coming back to
another video
take care everyone
goodbye